- Il y a des chambres qui
ne sont pas encore prêtes?
Ah, no
on m'avait dit que toutes
les chambres avaient été
nettoyées.
- La soirée commence à peine,
à l'hôtel Chrome, au centre-
ville de e e e e e e e e e e e n
les bras.
Les 150 places mises ànenenenen
situation d'itinérance atteintes
de la COVID sont déjà promises.
Et malgré l'existence
d'un deuxièmelalalalalalalalalas
le fait qu'on refuse des gens.
ÉMILIE FORTIER, resp. services
- Autant les personnes
en situation d'irararance
n'ont pas de place où aller
si elles sont en santé que c'esr
accès à une place d'isolement.
IlIlIl n'y a plus de place nulle
part. On est devant un dilemme :
est-ce que... le froidd'd'd'd'd?
C'est quoi le... c'est quoi
la priorité?
HUGUES GUILLAUME, directeur-
ad
- Le troisième, il est plein,
le quatrième est plein.
On est rendus maintenant
à six étages. À chaque fois,
c'était rempli, c'était complet.
- Voilà votre chambre
Vous avez les draps...
usagers, les intervenants
s'assurent qt t t t le monde
prend ses médicaments
de sevrage à ceux qui ont
des problèmes de consommation
pour rendre leur séjour
possible. Il n'y a toutefois pas
- Si vous présentez des
symptômes, on va vous ga
jusqu'à 10 jours.
- OK.
symptômes et que vous avez fait
deux vaccins, tuququququitter
après cinq jours.
- Brian et Micheenenenenent
une chambre depuis vendredi.
Et déjà, ils réfléchissent
période d'isolement.
BRIAN
- Je vais... Bien, je vais
en détox dans pas long
au centre Wapan au 30 janvier.
Puis,  p p p p place où aller,
ma mère va venir me chercher.
- Après ça, je vais me trouver
une chambrinininininir mes jours
au moins pas dans la rue.t t t t
frette. Je couchais dans les
portiques. Sur la rue Notre-
Dame, il
je couchais dans les portiquesrà
pendant deux, trois semaines.
Fait qu'à 75 ans, là
- En milieu de soirée, une bonne
peinent à se trouver un toit.
- Normalement, quand on est
en éclosion, on ne peut pas
par exemple, dans nos services
réguliers d'hébergement
d'urgence, mais là,
vu la situation, vu les grands
officielle de prioriser
les admissions et d'ou
un peu la COVID.
- llllllà de la création
de places dans les refuges,
c'est le personnel qualifié qui
des personnes dans la rue.
- J'ai reçu aujourd'hui
des courriels de médecins
comme ça, avec qui on a
travaillé dans le passé.
C'est super apprécié, mais...
t'sais, on a besoin
que quelqu'un va être là
de 8 à 4, 4 à min
d'avoir un... une coordination
dans... dans tout ça aussi.
(Toc! Toc!)
- À tantôt!
- C'est pour cette raison
d'itinérance atteintes de
la Ctre déplacées
bientôt au stade de soccer de
Montréal. L'endroit va permettrs
ressources sous un même toit.
- Même à 320, ça ne se
pour accueillir la...
l'augmentation des cas
pour les personnes en situation
d'itinéran
- Ils font leur gros possible.
- Dans une situa
évidente, hein?- On est chanceu,
parce que s'ils n'étaient pas
là, je ne sais pas ce qu'on
ferait.
accueillir ses premiers usagers
dès cette semaine. L
hôtels déjà mobilisés vont
devenir des zones vertes
qui ne trouvent pas de place
en refug